chase claypool not much of a mystery as
to what he did
outside of a bar in california because
it was caught on tape look big brother's
everywhere and it's
all of us we're all carrying around
that thing that is going to show what
you did where you did it and when you
did it and
tmz posted the video of claypool in a
fight that started inside a bar
reportedly ended up outside of the bar
at one point it looks like claypool
walks over and kicks a guy who's on the
ground
and then a guy lunges at claypool and
lands flat on his face and it looks like
claypool kind of
grabs his head and slaps it down onto
the asphalt for good measure
i don't know what comes to this no
criminal charges yet
there could be civil litigation
depending upon the extent of any
injuries and
given the reality that chase claypool
has you know
money that someone could try to obtain
via the civil justice system
but the nfl has to decide what to do
about this it's him
and you see him go up and kick somebody
if the nfl is going to have a consistent
and even-handed application of the
personal conduct policy
it's at least something they need to
look into even if it's a fine or a
warning or whatever
not the kind of behavior you want to see
one of your bright young players
involved in sharing
and this is the time of year mike that
nfl teams worry about their players
right because they're not at the team
facility a lot of them leave and go to
their off-season homes and they're there
and they have a lot of free time on
their hands so this is the time that
that players can get in trouble and
teams hope they do the right things but
we see a lot of these at this point in
the off season before the off season
program begins
hopefully this works out okay for chase
claypool and and the steelers but
you do worry about players this time of
year and he's had a heck of a
off season because we go back a couple
weeks ago you wrote about it about his
diva tendencies
uh that the the team website reporter
who's
in the know there we presume wrote about
some diva tendencies that the steelers
were worried about so
heck of an offseason so far for chase
claypool
and you know i remember when i first got
into this business it was like clockwork
the period of time between the end of
the season
and the start of the off-season program
and then the end of the off season
program back when it was even
more extensive than it is now of course
the nflpa wants there to be none
but during those two windows from let's
say january
to early april and from mid-june to the
start of training camp
players left to their own devices that's
when there was the uptick
in the things that got guys arrested
the things that caused problems for
players and for teams
and after the ray rice incident between
ray rice
greg hardy and adrian peterson when the
nfl beefed up the personal comic policy
and
introduced the concept of paid leave
that's when players started to get the
message
that there would be significant
consequences and i can't help but wonder
whether it's been so long
that the players who have cycled in
don't fully understand it you know it it
may be
maybe it's not a priority anymore to get
guys to understand what they shouldn't
do
and there aren't many examples currently
in the nfl of guys who have gotten
themselves into significant trouble
away from the field despite ongoing
incidents in houston
but but maybe you need a reminder every
once in a while maybe these teams do
need to do a better job and also last
year with the pandemic
no bar fights because nobody was in bars
so this is a new dynamic if you have a
reduced off season program
and things are getting back to normal
you're going to have guys back in
situations where they could get in
trouble and the teams need to know
that the players need to be fully
informed of what they should and
shouldn't do
and understand that someone is always
watching you and someone is always
recording you
that's right mike everything we do just
assume that it's on video that somebody
has it somewhere and it's going to come
out
and and act right and do the right
things and it doesn't sound like he was
the instigator
in this instance but that doesn't matter
i mean there is clear video of him
causing this fight kicking a guy and and
so just
just don't do some of the things that
you know think twice before you
you do something like this and i know
it's hard and i know
emotions play a part but if you're going
to go to bars and do things do all the
right things you know
get uber or whatever to to drive you
home and do the right things when you're
in that bar mike
and and when you see trouble you have to
have the instinct
to get away that's one of the things
i've tried to teach my son more than
anything else have an instinct
as to when you need to know to get out
of there for whatever reason
so you don't get drawn into it so it
doesn't it doesn't spill over onto you
you never know in this day and age who's
carrying a gun
you sense trouble you just get the hell
out just go just leave
nothing good is going to come out of
hanging around and possibly getting
sucked into some sort of a fracas and uh
that's good advice i think for anyone
but especially for folks in the nfl who
are going to be magnets
for someone who would love to be able to
say i got kicked in the face by chase
claypool
and i took chase claypool to court and i
got a verdict or settlement
from chase claypool because usually when
you're out of the bar and somebody kicks
you in the face
good luck collecting from them because
they're not going to have a ton of
assets especially
younger people hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports